almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it hey this is
really interesting there's a few
Republican governors who have been
ignoring if not completely abandoning
Donald Trump when it comes to dealing
with the virus in their states and their
popularity has absolutely exploded I'm
talking mostly about Ohio Republican
Governor Mike DeWine
he's done a pretty good job of handling
coronavirus from day one although more
recently there are some concerns about
the policies he's rolling out but he's
mostly been following health experts and
not Donald Trump and his popularity has
soared we also have been looking at how
Maryland Republican Governor Larry Hogan
has been dealing with the virus and then
our own governor here in Massachusetts
Charlie Baker a Republican as well has
been doing a pretty good job and the
reason that we care about this is that
the November of 2020 elections are in
many ways referendums that's the Ritz
not referenda I looked it up referendums
on Donald Trump when we look at the
Senate race in North Carolina with
Republican Thom Tillis or we look at
martha mcsalley in Arizona or you look
at Susan Collins in Maine these are in
large part adjudications of the Trump
regime and so far it's not going
particularly well for those Republicans
many Republicans have been afraid of
contradicting or crossing Donald Trump
because they're afraid it might be bad
for their local and state races Trump
might target me it could be really
really bad but what we're seeing is that
Ohio Republican Governor Mike DeWine has
absolutely split from Trump and he is
hugely benefiting from it in terms of
approval in terms of popularity and this
may be a signal for 2020 six months away
we can't say for sure but it may be a
signal what did Mike DeWine do Mike
DeWine lock down Ohio early before other
Republicans took it seriously before
Donald Trump was even taking it
seriously he's been doing regular
briefings that are actually fact-based
and they attract Democrats and
Republicans in Ohio and even nationally
people are watching these much like
Andrew Cuomo's briefings conservative
activists and business leaders have been
pressuring DeWine to do what Trump wants
start reopening do all this stuff and
DeWine just hasn't done it and he's been
listening to the health experts he also
came out in favor of a mail-in primary
late last month Trump has been viciously
opposed to mail and voting and then more
recently this week DeWine has started to
loosen up some of the guidelines as
businesses can start opening masks are
recommended six feet separation is
recommended for workers and customers
and for a while before this 30 or more
Republicans in the state legislature
were demanding that DeWine open
everything right away and he didn't do
it
splitting with Trump and his approval on
coronavirus is 85 percent his
trustworthiness rating is 89% on
coronavirus you don't get those numbers
with just Republicans he's taking
testing seriously he says they're going
to roughly triple testing by the end of
the month in Ohio from 7,000 a day to
20,000 a day and what's interesting is
that when we look at Maryland and
Massachusetts Republican governors in
blue states you kind of have to as a
Republican governor follow what your
liberal state legislators want you to do
Massachusetts has a Republican governor
and Charlie Baker but a very left
legislature and a relatively left voting
public so it's not surprising that
Charlie Baker is doing more what our
state wants rather than what Trump wants
but Ohio it's certainly a battleground
state but it's not a left-wing
stronghold of any kind so you might
imagine that what Mike DeWine has done
in abandoning Trump would be far more
risky but it has worked here in
Massachusetts Charlie Baker former CEO
of a big health insurance company I
didn't vote for him I'm not looking to
have more and more governors be former
CEOs of health insurance companies but
Charlie Baker knows how to delegate he
knows how to trust experts and he knows
how to look at data remember that dr.
Berks laughably claimed that Trump looks
at data and makes decisions by
assimilating the information we all knew
it was BS what we want to see is
governor's actually do what DeWine has
been doing to some degree with Charlie
Baker and Hogan have been doing I'm
hopeful that as a result on May 18th
here in Massachusetts Charlie Baker will
be able to announce some loosening of
certain guidelines if the numbers keep
improving yesterday here in
Massachusetts we had only one point four
percent case growth that's really low we
had a week of about three percent daily
case growth that's really not bad so
competence is important ideology is less
important here armed protesters aside
for the most part we've seen people
across the country approve of competence
even across party lines Massachusetts
voters overwhelmingly pleased with the
Republican Charlie Baker despite being a
blue state Ohio voters Democrats and
Republicans nearly 90 percent approval
on a coronavirus trustworthiness for the
Republican governor who has abandoned
the doctrine of Donald Trump again this
may be a big signal for how November of
2020 may go hopefully we don't know
we've gotta count every single vote we
have to cast every ballot but that is
the upside to what we are seeing will
have continued coverage of this on the
David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show
follow me while you're there at David
Pakman 2